Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Von wegen Rasenfunk-Sommerpause. Die Diskussion rund um den Rücktritt von Mesut Özil hat auch uns so sehr beschäftigt, dass es jetzt dazu hier eine Folge gibt, mit Fatih Demireli, dem Chefredakteur vom Sokrates Magazin. Fatih, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Hi. Ja, jetzt muss es doch eine Rasenfunk-Folge geben. Ich wollte eigentlich eine kleine Sommerpause machen. Wir haben uns gerade auch schon drüber unterhalten. Du hättest auch noch anderes zu tun gehabt, als diese Mesut Özil-Debatte irgendwie abzufedern. Aber da kam uns dann all das dazwischen. Was passiert ist im Nachgang nach der Weltmeisterschaft? Und weil das so ein großes Thema ist, dass ich glaube, dass wir da auch noch ein paar Jahre drüber sprechen, gibt es jetzt auch einen Kurzpass dazu. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich dich mit dabei habe. Schön, dass du Zeit hast.
Es wirft ein schlechtes Licht auf den kompletten Verband.
Ganz extrem.
Was die nächste Frage stellt, wir kommen ein bisschen weg von der Kauser Özil. Aber weil eben aus diesem Foto und aus dem Rücktritt der Vorwurf des Rassismus offen wurde, den Özil aufgebracht hat, wo auch viele Leute gesagt haben, was hat denn das mit Rassismus zu tun, wo ich jetzt erstmal die Haltung vertreten würde, so viel Haltung gestehe ich mir jetzt hier in diesem Podcast zu, dass ich sagen würde, also wenn jemand selbst sagt, er würde rassistisch beleidigt, dann steht das jetzt erstmal anderen Leuten nicht zu, das nicht anzuerkennen, sondern da muss man dann schon erstmal bitte diesen Vorwurf nachgehen. Und ehrlich gesagt ist das auch eine Internetrecherche von 0,03 Sekunden, dass du rassistische Beleidigungen über Mesut Özil lesen kannst im Internet. Also das muss jemandem schon zugestanden sein, dass er dann auch die Rassismus, jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt die Karte spielt, das ist natürlich Quatsch, aber dass er Rassismus als Rassismus benennt, das muss jedem erstmal zugestehen. Aber dann sind wir ja auch... Dann haben wir eben diesen Verband und die Art und Weise, wie er sich nicht dazu äußert. Die Mitspieler nicht, der Mannschaftsrat nicht, der über DFB-Präsident und Sportdirektor haben wir schon kurz zumindest gesprochen, sehr, sehr schwierig. Und das führt mich dann eigentlich zu einer anderen Frage, die ich auch ganz gerne in dem Zusammenhang jetzt mal diskutiert hätte, was aber gerade nicht stattfindet. Was tut denn eigentlich der DFB gegen rechtsgerichtete Fans? Denn die hat der DFB. Wir hatten Vorkommnisse beim Auswärtsspiel in Prag. Übrigens konnte niemand von denen identifiziert werden. Ist auch so ein bisschen in der Medienlandschaft untergegangen. Trotz aller hochauflösenden Bilder, die man von den Leuten da hatte, konnte niemand tatsächlich nachgewiesen werden. Er hätte da sich an den rechtsradikalen Parolen geäußert. Was tut der DFB gegen rechte Fans? Denn wenn Mesut Özil zum Beispiel in seinem Statement selbst schreibt, er sei rassistisch beleidigt worden nach einem Spiel der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, dann ist das doch eine absolut virulente und wichtige Frage.
Es kann sein, dass der DFB keine Zeit hat, gegen Rechte was zu tun hat. Man muss ja Hashtags erfütten und man muss tolle Teamhotels raussuchen. Da bleibt dann keine Zeit, um mit rechten Fans in der Sicht zu bewegen.
Jetzt habe ich den Chefredakteur von Sokrates in die Problemik getrieben.
Soweit ist es gekommen, Fatih.
Du musst mir die Frage jetzt auch nicht beantworten. Aber warum wird diese Frage nicht gestellt? Es wirkt doch so, dass es da blinde Flecken fast gibt. Und während über alle anderen Dinge sich viele orten, also lass jemand eine Pyro-Fackel anzünden im Stadion. Und du wirst sofort 100 Haltungen dazu lesen, in denen es heißt, das ist kein Fußball, das sind sogenannte Fußballfans, das macht den Fußball kaputt. Und ich will jetzt nicht die Pyro-Debatte verharmlosen oder rechtfertigen oder so weiter. Aber warum ist das denn bei solchen Dingen nicht genauso? Und wenn ich lese, ein deutscher Fan hat einen deutschen Nationalspieler rassistisch beleidigt. Und es gibt, wenn ich mir gleichzeitig umgucke und ich nicht glaube, dass das komplett an den Haaren herbeigezogen ist, das kann ich mir sehr, sehr gut vorstellen, wenn ich die aktuelle Debatte verfolge, dann muss doch die Frage gestellt werden, was kann man denn gegen solche Ressentiments tun, wenn sie auch im Fußballumfeld aufkommen? Denn das passt doch auch nicht zu den ach so tollen deutschen Werten.
Max, man muss es wollen. Ich glaube, wenn man will, dass man dieses Thema zu bekämpfen, dann kriegt man das auch hin. Wir leben in einer Zeitalter, in der Technik man so viel erlaubt, mit auflesenden Kameras, mit allem, worum man dann, und Gottes Willen, ich bin auch nicht dafür, dass man jetzt jeden einzelnen Fan beobachten muss, aber sowas kann man relativ schnell rausfinden. Und wenn man das Thema lösen will, man kann es lösen. Ich möchte dem DFB nicht absprechen, dass man, also nicht mal jetzt runterschwellig, ich glaube nicht, dass der DFB sich freut, wenn ein paar Rechte da auf den Rechten auf den Längen setzen und Spieler beleidigen. Ich glaube, das wollen sie definitiv nicht. Warum sollen sie das wollen?
Nein, glaube ich auch nicht. Wollte ich damit auch nicht unterstellen.
Nein, nein, ich weiß, ich weiß. Aber ich verstehe diese Ignoranz dann nicht. Das ist ja ein offensichtliches Problem. Das Problem hat ja auch nicht nur Mesut Özil. Mesut Özil ist heute weg. Jetzt ist NK Günder noch da. Es ist Emre Can noch da. In den U-Mannschaften sind viele Türken, da kommen alle hoch. Es sind auch nicht nur die Deutsch-Türken, es gibt ja noch ein paar andere auch. Das müsste Punkt eins sein auf der Agenda. Weil es ist immer noch so. Es ist schlimm genug, was wir hier leben. Aber es gibt noch eine Welt da draußen, die gerade sehr genau schaut, was die Deutschen gerade machen. Mesut Özil hat sich auf Englisch geäußert. Er ist dadurch aufmerksam stark geworden. Man hat gesehen, wer sich alles dazu geäußert hat. Arsenal hat sich hinter Mesut gestellt. Viele Berühmtheiten, viele Meinungsmacher haben sich hinter Özil gestellt. Da stehen die Deutschen gerade in der Kritik. Ganz extrem. Nicht nur in der Türkei, ganz und gar nicht. Es ist auf der ganzen Welt. Und jetzt ist der DFB und Deutschland gefordert, Maßnahmen zu treffen. Keine Visi-Vasi-Maßnahmen, sondern wirklich Maßnahmen, die effektiv sind, um dieses anscheinend vorhandene Ressismusproblem entscheidend gegenüberzutreten. Das muss jetzt gemacht werden. Da gibt es gar keine Alternative. Wenn bisher nichts gemacht wurde, dann muss sich der DFB zusammensetzen und eine Lösung finden. Ich habe kein Sicherheitsexperte, das ich sagen kann, dass soll gemacht werden. Ich bin auch nicht dafür. Ich kenne es außer der Türkei. In der Türkei gab es viele Jahre große Probleme. Auf den längeren Stadien mit der Gewalt. Das wurde irgendwann mit elektronischen Tickets gelöst. Deutlich viel sicher geworden, deutlich weniger Sachen. Aber ich bin nicht dafür. Das ist mir eine Spur zu heftig. Aber ich glaube schon, dass man so etwas kontrollieren kann. Man kann da entscheidend gegen übertreten. So viel Macht, so viel Einfluss hat der DFB dann schon.
Es soll nicht falsch verstanden werden. Auch an der Stelle darf jeder Mensch seine Meinung haben. Und Leute dürfen Mesut Özil auch doof finden. Sie dürfen ihn auch aufgrund seiner Herkunft doof finden. Aber Artikel 1 gut gesetzt. Die Würde des Menschen ist unenthassbar. Sie zu achten und zu schützen, ist die Verpflichtung aller staatlichen Gewalten. Und nicht nur der staatlichen Gewalten, sondern auch der Gesellschaft. Es gibt Grenzen, die dürfen im Zusammenleben nicht übertreten werden. Dazu gehört dann zum Beispiel eine rassistische Beleidigung. Das ist keine Meinungsäußerung mehr, die vom Grundgesetz gedeckt ist. Und da muss man dann eben etwas tun. Ich bin jetzt fast froh, dass du auch gesagt hast, du weißt jetzt auch gar nicht, was man da machen würde. Das ist ja das Schwierige an dieser Debatte. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir eine Fan-ID einführen und dann haben wir keine Ressentiments mehr unter Fußballerhängern. Die Debatte ist größer als der Fußball und wird jetzt aber anhand des Fußballs gerade ins Rampenlicht gezogen. Mir fehlt da eben schon die Diskussion darüber. Da ist Rassismus ein großes Wort. Wenn du über Ressentiments sprichst, kannst du darüber fast schon nicht mehr unaufgeregt sprechen. Denn da fühlen sich viele Leute sofort angegriffen. Oder es fängt auch sehr früh so ein What-about-ism an. Also was ist denn eigentlich mit denen? Ja, aber es gibt ja auch linksradikale Straftaten. Und es gibt auch das. Und hast du nicht auch hier das gesagt? Also da wird sehr schnell mit dem Finger gezeigt und man lenkt es von der eigentlichen Debatte weg. Aber das ist doch eigentlich der Kern, um den es hier gehen sollte. Und wir haben begonnen bei einem Foto mit einem türkischen Staatspräsidenten, wie auch immer wir den finden wollen. Und jetzt sind wir gelandet bei einer Debatte rund um das Thema. Haben wir in Deutschland einen Rückschritt gemacht, was dem angeht, wie wir Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund begegnen? Oder ist es vielleicht gar kein Rückschritt, sondern es sind nur Ressentiments, die jetzt deutlicher sichtbar geworden sind, die es vielleicht schon immer gab? Und vielleicht ist das die eigentliche Debatte, die geführt werden muss. Und sicherlich ist deswegen dieses Thema so groß.
Es ist definitiv ein Rückschritt da. Ich habe vorhin gesagt, dass es da durchaus eine Entwicklung gab in den letzten Jahren in die richtige Richtung. Aber wir sind an einem Punkt angelangt, in dem unser Innenminister abgeschobene Flüchtlinge zählt. Und abgeschobene Menschen zählt, in der wir ernsthaft darüber sprechen, ob man Menschen enttricken lässt oder nicht. Das zeigt alles gerade, dass, okay, Meinungsausführungen, ja, soll, darf man. Aber das sind für mich keine Themen, über die man sprechen darf. Also diese Flüchtlingsdebatte hat etwas aufgewühlt. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Es hat irgendwas aufgefühlt. Es hat auch teilweise Mut, den Menschen Mut gemacht, noch klarer vielleicht jede versteckte Meinung zu machen. Vielleicht haben wir uns gar nicht entwickelt, sondern haben einfach alle jede Meinung versteckt. Und auf einmal haben alle den Mut, sich so zu äußern, wie sie es gerade tun. Also der Rückschritt ist da, definitiv. Es zeigt nicht nur der Fall Mesut Özil gerade, es zeigt einige Probleme, über die wir reden. Es zeigt die Menschen gerade, die im Bundestag sitzen, in den verschiedenen Landtagen sitzen. Ich unterstelle nicht jede Menschen, der AfD wählt, dass er komplett recht eingestellt ist. Da ist irgendwas passiert in den letzten Monaten, Jahren, dass sich so eine Bewegung eingesetzt hat. Vielleicht ist es auch nicht nur ein Deutschlandproblem, sondern das zieht sich ja gerade durch die ganze Welt. Ich glaube, an dem Punkt bin ich jetzt tatsächlich, dass ich jetzt sage, das ist auch kein großes Problem. Es passiert gar nichts in der Welt. Wir haben das große Pech, dass wir in dieser Welle gerade mittendrin sitzen. Ich weiß, aber ich habe auch eine äußere Befürchtung, dass das nicht so leicht aufzuhalten ist. Es wird immer mehr, es wird nicht weniger. Aber wir haben in Deutschland einfach auch aufgrund unserer Vielfalt, die hier da ist, und den vielleicht dann gegenzutreten. Aber da muss ja auch jemand mal anfangen. Es hilft einfach nicht, das jetzt noch weiter zu befreuen. Deswegen habe ich auch vorhin gesagt, wir müssen vom Gas gehen. Das hilft für alle. Wir müssen irgendwo einen U-Plan zu ziehen.
Ja, in Kaufbeuren wurde jetzt der Neubau einer Moschee nach Bürgerentscheid abgelehnt. Es ist jetzt nur ein kleines Detail, es ist auch ein bisschen untergegangen, aber so weit ist es, dass die Angst vor anderen, vor dem Fremden, vor Religionen so groß ist, dass man sie nicht mehr ausüben lässt.
So, und an dem Punkt sagen dann viele Deutsch-Türken, was wäre, wenn in Ankara der Bau einer Kirche abgelehnt worden wäre? Wie wäre das angekommen? Also nur, um mal eine Einschätzung zu geben, wie die Menschen denken.
Genau, und eigentlich sind wir dann aber auch schon bei dem gelandet, was diese Debatten so schwierig macht, nämlich Fingerpointing. Und dann geht es eigentlich gar nicht mehr um die Sache. Und die eigentliche Sache ist doch, wenn wir über Werte sprechen, zu denen man sich bekennen muss, als DFB, als Deutsche, als Gesellschaft, dann muss man die Werte erleben. Und dazu gehören viele Dinge, die in dieser Debatte nicht gemacht werden. Und dieses Aufgeregte in dieser Debatte hat ganz viel damit zu tun, dass die Leute in einem Wertekanon sich befinden und den verteidigen mit Mann und Maus. Und dieser Wertekanon aber offensichtliche Lücken hat, weil eben Dinge passieren, wie eben das im Mittelmeer Flüchtlinge ertrinken und da dann doch eine nicht unterschätzende Zahl der Deutschen sagt, ja, recht so. Wir haben Videos, wo Leute absaufen, skandieren in Deutschland. Und wir haben das auch genügend. Auf der anderen Seite des politischen Spektrums haben wir auch Meinungen, die sich nicht mit den Werten decken. Und das, glaube ich, ist die Ursache, warum diese Diskussionen auch so schnell an Schärfe gewinnen und warum sie so schnell so verstrickt werden. Also ich habe den Eindruck, in dieser ganzen Debatte geht es weder nach vorne noch nach hinten. Und ich hatte angefangen diese Sendung, indem ich gesagt habe, wir wollen so ein bisschen Impulse geben, ein paar Fragen stellen, die sonst wenig gestellt werden und nicht das große Ganze besprechen. Und wir sind doch selbst wieder beim Großen und Ganzen gelandet, Fatih. Wir haben eigentlich gar nicht das eingehalten, was wir uns vorgenommen hatten. Ich habe jetzt auch einige meiner Fragen gar nicht gestellt. Aber vielleicht ist das auch, ich glaube, das steht für die Debatte. Du kannst, es geht, wie gesagt, es ging los mit einem einfachen Foto eines Nationalspielers. Und jetzt steht hier der Max in seinem Aufnahmestudio und erzählt was von Werten und für die man eintreten muss und fühlt sich auf einmal, als wäre er Pfarrer. Ohne jetzt, dass ich gerade eine Religion predigen würde, sondern Pfarrer des Grundgesetzes. Vielleicht ist es sinnbildlich für die ganze Debatte und warum sie so geführt wird, wie sie gerade geführt wird.
Ja, es ist so. Ich glaube, man kommt gar nicht drum herum, wenn man über Özil spricht, dann man das Ganze ganz und sehen. Ich finde es auch gut, weil ich finde, jetzt ist auch eine Chance da. Wir sagen, es muss etwas gemacht werden. Wir wissen zwar nicht was, aber es muss etwas gemacht werden. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt schon eine Gelegenheit, zu sagen, so jetzt, jetzt kommen wir nicht mehr drum herum. Jetzt ist der Vorwurf da. Der Vorwurf ist nicht nur von einer Person, sondern sie wächst. Sie begriff viele, viele Menschen, die in diesem Land leben. Das sind auch nicht nur Menschen, die Integrationsuntergrund haben, sondern auch viele Menschen, die keine Integrationsuntergrund haben, fühlen ja diese Probleme. Und jetzt ist einfach auch eine Chance da, zu sagen, so, jetzt machen wir mal was und wir machen jetzt wirklich etwas, was auch vielleicht einen gewissen Effekt hat. Und zwar, dass sich die Menschen wieder zueinander finden, dass man diese Schärfe herausnimmt, dass Integration wirklich wieder nicht durch einseitig im Einpeitschen geschieht, sondern dass man da den Dialog sucht, weil so eine Integration kannst du nicht einseitig machen. Du musst dem Menschen das Gefühl geben, dass du sie auch integrieren willst und nicht hier dulden willst. Und wenn du das schaffst, kommen wir auch wieder auf ein Level, das erhältlich ist. Dazu muss man auch sagen, und das ist immer so in Gesprächen, dass man dann versucht, so ein Happy End zu finden. Es gibt dann auch genug Menschen in diesem Land, die auf beiden Seiten, die es schaffen, nebeneinander zu leben und sich nicht gegenseitig Scheiße zu finden. Zum Glück ist es ja auch die Mehrzahl und Mehrheit. Und ich, als jemand, der Mesut Özil nachhelfen kann, fühle mich nach wie vor sehr, sehr wohl. Ich habe mich nicht integriert. Ich bin ein Teil der Gesellschaft, ich muss mich nicht integrieren. Und das fühle ich mich nach wie vor. Und ich werde auch meinen Beitrag dazu leisten, dass es auch anderen so geht, das, was ich kann. Ich habe jetzt nicht die Macht, und ich möchte ja auch nicht haben, jeden da mit dran zu ziehen, aber das, was ich kann, das tue ich. Und das ist, glaube ich, die Aufgabe von uns allen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein schönes Schlusswort. Ich hoffe, dass wir mit dieser Sendung Fatih etwas beigetragen haben zur Debatte, bei der viele Hörerinnen und Hörer sagen, das hat sie jetzt doch bereichert und war dann nicht der Beitrag Nummer XY mit den immer gleichen Argumenten. Ich bin gespannt, wie die Diskussion weiterläuft. Ich würde mir bei allem wünschen, was jetzt auch wahrscheinlich im Forum zu dieser Folge diskutiert wird, auf YouTube, in den sozialen Netzwerken, Menschlichkeit. Ach, ich war heute mit großen Worten um mich herum. Aber zur Menschlichkeit gehört eine Form des Umgangs. Und auch Leute, es wird viele Leute geben, die mit vielem nicht übereinstimmen, was auch ich hier gesagt habe, die das kritisieren werden. Und es wird vielleicht auch Leute geben, die übereinstimmen mit Dingen, die wir sagen. Aber der Ton macht da die Musik. Und bitte lasst uns ordentlich miteinander diskutieren, auch wenn wir unterschiedliche Meinungen haben. Ich erträge dieses Rumgeschrei nicht mehr. Und ich habe auch schon selbst E-Mails bekommen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, wo lebe ich ja eigentlich? Bitte lasst uns in einer vernünftigen Art und Weise weiter reden. Und dir, Fatih, danke ich, dass du mit mir hier geredet hast. Der längste Kurzpass aller Zeiten, ich verpasse meinen Anschlusstermin. Aber es ging jetzt nicht kürzer. Und trotzdem haben wir noch nicht mal alle Dinge abgehandelt. Aber vielen, vielen Dank, Fatih, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast für diesen Kurzpass.
Sehr gerne. Max auch vielen Dank für die Sendung. Ich fand auch, dass die Länge es verdient hat. Und ja, lass uns positiv sein, dass das auch alles wieder in die richtige Richtung geht.
Man kann dir auf Twitter folgen. Das ist ein deutschsprachiger Count. Soweit ist es nämlich gekommen. Der Fatih twittert zweisprachig. Unglaublich. Es ist unglaublich. Vielen Dank, Fatih Demireli, Chefredakteur vom Sokrates Sportmagazin. Dem denkenden Sportmagazin sei an dieser Stelle auch sehr empfohlen. Und man hat, glaube ich, auch einen Eindruck bekommen, was das bedeutet, wenn man denkt und wenn man einen weiten Horizont hat und dann auch mal auf Fragen nicht nur mit Ja oder Nein antwortet, weil der Horizont soweit ist. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich hoffe, die Folge ist auf euer Gehör nicht nur gestoßen, sondern auch auf gefallen. Lasst uns die Diskussion sinnvoll weiterführen. Ich bin gespannt, freue mich drauf. Bis bald, macht's gut.